hola mi nombre es natalia y te vengo a
hacer una invitación
te quiero invitar a que hagamos sin
nadie si sinergia a unir fuerzas unir
objetivos para lograr algo único
generalmente inesperado hoy vamos a
hacer uno más uno y nos va a dar tres
se cuenta un poquito por qué estoy tan
entusiasmada y enamorada de esa palabra
que significa tanto para mí
me dedico al rubro de la moda soy
emprendedora tengo una tienda de
indumentaria de ropa y quería
preadolescentes en el interior de
uruguay esa pose y estoy bastante
alejada del centro comercial
muy apasionada con este nuevo pienso que
fue para mí este entendimiento empecé a
ver qué bueno que había que hacer algo
que había que llamar la atención para
que no mirarán y viniera la compra
no era sola
había que mirar hacia afuera
y había que buscar ayuda
también me di cuenta en ese proceso de
mirar para afuera que otros
emprendedores del área de la imagen
también querían mostrar su trabajo
y ahí aparecen fotógrafos maquilladoras
peluqueras
que colaboran
y qué aportan a crear una imagen de
nuestro producto superado a y uno más
uno dio tres empezamos a usar redes
de nombrarnos unos a otros a
recomendarnos y mucha gente elogios de
trabajo empezaron a clavar la mirada ahí
hay algo y vimos que por ahí
entonces empezamos a pensar un poquito
más más alto
a redoblar la apuesta
se crearon ferias
en esas ferias no sólo había moda había
gastronomía
una pintora muy joven expuso sus cuadros
y cantantes de todo tipo vinieron porque
no fue una sino varias medias
aparecieron tatuadores artesanas
y gel que nuestro emprendimiento se
llenó distinto
lo hicimos cobrar una vida inesperada
y se fueron tomando decisiones de que
por ahí iba la cosa hasta que llegó el
momento en que no nos unimos con otros
emprendedores
y creamos el primer evento
en un lugar emblemático de san josé
incluso sea el de san josé
que también hizo sinergia
con
nuestro emprendimiento con nuestro
emprendimiento de ropa también y ahí
aparecieron más peluqueras más
maquilladoras también hubo una feria se
mostraron los de sant tías cantantes
bailarines gente que trabaja con audio y
luces que mostraron con el nivel que
trabaja
entonces plantamos una semillita la
comunidad vio
que se pueden hacer un montón de cosas
resonaron nuestros nombres el nombre de
entendimientos se conocieron artistas
pujantes que estaban saliendo y que
quizás de otra manera lo piensan
por eso te quiero invitar
a que mires un poquito para poder
seguramente vos
así sinergia mucho más de lo que hizo
con 7
segura estoy de que si te pones a pensar
un ratito
hace sinergia 10
muchas veces moverse energías y lograr
cosas mucho más grandes cuando te unix
qué beneficios tiene usted de hoy algún
dato más para compensar
para enamorarte como estoy yo enamorada
de este proceso
la puerta flexibilidad
porque vos te acostumbras
a escuchar a otros a ver otros puntos de
venta
y en este mundo de constantes cambios y
más ahora en lo que nos está tocando a
todos una manera de vivir
de tantos vaivenes imprevistos que la
vida nos sorprende a veces no gratamente
es necesario tener la flexibilidad
pegar el volantazo
para cambiar de dirección apoyado en una
pared
capaz que tiene preguntas y yo estaré
preparado para hacerlo
te hago las preguntas
la pasión a lo que haces
estás dispuesto a dar a ayudar
crees contar tu historia eres que el
mundo sepa lo estás haciendo queréis que
funcione
segura
lárgate como
conectando dando tu sitio primero a vos
conecta con vos con tu pasión decirte
que si lo tuyo a pesar
des a mirar para afuera con ojos de
explorador deslumbrante
el proyecto de tu comunidad os encanta
con quien que desconecta
a quién quieres escribirle y decirle
vamos a hacer algo
por dónde va lo tuyo
seguramente vas a encontrarte con otra
gente con otros otras propuestas que te
van a dar el sí ya a veces vas a tener
que cambiar de dirección vas a decir por
acá no era también está bien ahí vas a
crecer
adiós a volar
y ahí te vas a dar cuenta
el mundo de posibilidades que hay allá
afuera
y vas a dejar una parte de vos en otros
porque de eso se trata hacer sinergia
estaría transformado pero sin perder la
identidad
y en el camino en el proceso que nos
termina nunca y es maravilloso y
dinámico
vas a disfrutar mucho vas a crecer
y vas a hacer principalmente que otro
crezca
porque por ahí pasa por el disfrute esa
te aseguro que va a ser la mayor
ganancia
hagamos sinergia yo te invito